hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to alien isolation we
are in the nest
of the queen of the aliens which is why
i'm on the pause screen
also it was really hot in the last
episode so i decided to get a glass of
ice water
i apologize if i drink it throughout the
episode
but i'm incredibly thirsty okay let's go
back into this
we are looking to release the lockdown
or no we're trying to restore power so
that we can then
release the lockdown please don't let
that attract him
right there that would be literally the
worst
what is going on
what's happening right now oh okay um
um um this is the wrong place wrong
place where the hell am i supposed to go
oh that's bad
that's right that's right baby that's
right you made a mistake i'm almost out
of flamethrower field but you made a
terrible error god damn you
goddamn all of this screw all of this
to alien hell
you don't know i'm here you don't know
where i
am oh my god i have no idea what
direction i'm supposed to go to be able
to get to that
oh oh god damn it i'm supposed to go all
the way back there
well that's stupid as hell screw you in
everything you want me to do
i'm just trying to survive the alien
threat here you're sending me on a wild
goose chain for
power hello
goodbye oh i'm so out of
i'm
can i kill you with guns
really really with this
i really hope that's just one of you
because you are a persistent
son of a [ __ ]
that's right that's right i should have
just gone this way the first time
if i just gone up here i would have been
accomplished my task and i would have
been off
ripley would have been dancing her way
out of this stupid scenario
not that she would be the one to do much
oh god really
really oh ha
how how do i get to where i need to go
oh oh
oh this is bad news bears
where the hell am i supposed to go
or hell where are we
go how uh am i supposed to go that way
but i think that was blocked off how is
that gonna circle all the way back to
where i need to go
this is all stupid there's damn aliens
everywhere trying to eat majiblets
and then small aliens don't want to
jibble my eatlets
and then big medium aliens don't want to
eat
all my gibblers i don't know i'm
confused
aliens okay anyway
so he's stomping around over there but
he does not know it
he doesn't know i'm over here yet recess
god stop doing that okay so there had to
be another way to go
about this way maybe no there's just a
dead guy that i'm gonna search and take
his stuff it was a shure
she i don't know i don't wanna risk the
molotov because apparently
that was a ghost okay you can't add
ghosts with alien
they completely conflict oh my god
what if they're ghost aliens alien
ghosts
oh here it is goddamn that took me
forever to find
you guys didn't see all of it because i
wouldn't subject you to that
that took me forever to find it was so
oh not obvious
even though it had a bright shining
light on it i guess but then again i'm
in a panic situation
aliens aliens
aliens aliens trying to kill me
okay so come on come back get this done
get this dern so that i can get my
non-alien very human butt
out of here ha ha now you're all
thinking of ripley's butt
okay now think of the aliens butt
you like that mental image you like that
so i don't know if the bolt gun's gonna
be any sort of good against that guy
i don't even know why they gave me the
good old guy but a little gun
okay bye thanks for stopping by
it's been a treat i'm just gonna
activate this here reactor
something an alien like you wouldn't
understand advanced
human technology the likes of which
you've never seen
so yeah now i gotta disengage the
locking mechanism
something you wouldn't know about you
know doors and locks and privacy because
you're an alien son of a [ __ ]
okay overload the beta core well that
sounds impressive
but what does that entail ooh good more
more
stuff actually i know exactly what
entails because i did it already
okay there's one down the other one
easy peasy lemon squeezy get it done get
it done get it done
okay cool cool cool cool cool cool all
cool all cool in this neighborhood
i know i gotta get out of here what do
you think i've been trying to do this
whole time
you're the one who walked into this [ __ ]
and decided to stay
when are you going to learn that you
just all you need to do is get in your
spacesuit
time your jump jump out to the spaceship
out there if it doesn't see you it'll
swing back around
i know you don't no i don't
that's right run away little
well that sounds all kinds of horrible
not sure if worse or less than last time
oh no no no no
oh definitely overreacted
probably soaked myself in nepal probably
did
yep still doesn't help me okay so i just
gotta get out of here
that's all i gotta do ain't no little
baby aliens gonna snarl my flower blues
anybody out there want a girl about my
rulers
you look important ah
i'm out here i'm out
i'm out whoa
stop making noises
i said no you come at me at your own
risk i got just enough fuel to deal with
you
yes i did it i did it i got out
i'm the best good for me
alien sons of [ __ ] well i guess i
can't complain i am in their
neighborhood
you know space put yourself in enough
danger today
i can power up all the cores overload
them and then initiate a reactor purge
it'll destroy everything down there yay
i'm not trying to persuade you out of
this ring
i just like if you
there are emergency overflow circuits
that feed excess power into the local
capacitor banks on each tower
if i decouple them and discharge the
system the purge will be external
the nest is right in harm's way
just find something to hold on to oh he
don't need to worry he's a way up there
in security
he's gonna be just fine and danny he's
got all sorts of androids and whatnot to
look
over him okay so i need to go over to
alphacore release
oh hi you don't know i'm here yet oh you
know what i'm just gonna kill you
i know it doesn't just fall over please
whatever whatever at least i got more
room to run here
uh i know i know i know you're a badass
weird robot with red glowing eyes
yes really
there we go
and thank you let me just reload here
this is
gonna take a while so just don't come
too close to me i i need to take care of
this before i get you
got how many of you are there fine you
know what screw you whoa
you're new uh shotgun for you
i guess i'm going to start with beta
because that seems good
don't run why not don't want me to blow
this whole place to hell and back
that's exactly what i'd like to do
unless i need to do alpha first
uh no apparently
oh god it was all the way down there
i need to look at my map more because i
need to be more cautious about exactly
where i'm going
come on come on come on
where am i oh god damn it how do i keep
moving past it
i thought i looked right at it it didn't
do anything oh there we go oh
okay chunk okay this should have taken
me like two seconds to do but i've said
it took like forever
where is oh god go
i know i know i know bad stuff okay whoa
what is
what am i doing
oh i see i need to balance the values ah
androids androids androids okay where
are they
oh they weren't anywhere nearby oh yes
they are
he's right there okay you know i'm just
going to kill these guys because i don't
want to take care of them
i'm going to try this bolt gun
so this is the longer i hold it down the
more accurate it becomes
bam baby this is what i was supposed to
be using but in the
original i didn't know what to do with
it oh it changed uh
stop stop stop stop stop stop okay
come on come on come on
come on come on no androids oh god damn
it
gotcha okay yay that's done so now i
need to release the beta release
and then overload the beta core which is
going to have another fun mini game for
me
come on come on come on what come on
yeah of course
yeah that's what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to do it
anytime you want to let me do it you
know i'm right here i'm ready to go come
on come on come on
what are you doing oh the alpha core is
not done yet okay i didn't know that
there was more parts of the albacore
how would i both know i'm just making
assumptions here on the mega cool
awesome sci-fi adventure that i'm on
so you ah damn it
damn it okay uh damn it
okay there we go that minigame is weird
okay overload the beta core i know i
know i know i'm on my way i'm on my way
i got it wait what was that is that the
sound of more androids on their way
because i really don't know if that was
the sound of more androids on their way
no no no no don't shoot that there's
nothing to shoot
ripley's getting a little shoot crazy
come on come on come on
more mini games more lots of fun before
we blow all these aliens helen back
there's no like confirmation beep it's
just
come on
i'm in a hurry
oh there we go god it just has to be at
the very
very end of those things one more one
more one more
one more one more come on okay i gotta
balance these
uh i guess good enough
well that's not going to balance the
values how do i do that
they don't get balanced
oh balance to the bottom i thought it
was balanced between each other i didn't
know that it was balanced to the bottom
numbers
okay whoa whoa whoa what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
to get out of here there's jesus dude
lots and lots of aliens
you're gonna be a problem
i'm gonna go around you i'm just gonna
run all the way around and i'm gonna be
totally
fine because i don't need to worry about
you guys i need to worry about
everything else that's going on
okay they were too stupid to circle
around the other way so i just got a gun
out here
bye which everybody am i supposed to go
i'm guessing i need to go through
uh wait am i just uh reactor maintenance
have been copper
oh come on god damn it with this thing
and they're going the wrong way
always always with this making me go the
wrong way making me think that something
else is going on
and i don't know because i don't always
read
the exact instructions all right so it
just tells me words i don't know where
they are overload the reaction thing i
thought that meant that everything was
gonna blow up and now i need to get the
hell out of here but apparently i need
to do this now okay not complaining
just a little bit stressed about the
situation
okay initiate purge from reactor control
oh it's over there isn't it god damn you
this is just annoying at this point i
just want to blow it up
why is it so hard to blow everything up
my b to blow skills are unbelievably
incredible i should not be this hard
to blow everything up what is going on
oh god that doesn't feel good
we're in a bit of a crisis situation
excuse me i'm a professional explosive
engineer
or something like that i have no idea
yep
bad bad i know come on come on come on
where are we going oh i see come on come
on
okay at least this is a little more
common here now i get to climb up
i get to take care of the androids and i
get to take care of the aliens all in
one fell swoop
and i'm sure that everything will be
happy after that and i'll be able to go
home and have a good old time
maybe
okay i'm guessing this isn't exactly a
self-destruct protocol because this
isn't like cataclysmically ending
everything but
boom here we go i don't wait what am i
doing here initiate purge with up down
okay then i don't know what that did
urge okay i'm about to purge the nest
hang tight
hang tight here we go hold on to your
butts everybody boosky
that's not good well
that didn't kill him yeah that did not
kill him
no i did not kill
huh [ __ ] i'm sorry ricardo
just get back to the marshall bureau
please
you got it ricardo we're on our way out
here still don't know where taylor went
oh boy i guess i gotta be very careful
again
i knew that wouldn't kill him it's just
electricity
huh i can't even kill him with bullets
apparently
okay well actually you can kill him with
bullets that's
shown in the movies the only reason they
didn't do it in the first movie is
because they didn't have
guns like on that thing that's why they
had to get the flamethrower because it
was just an improvised weapon something
weird
you think i need you to get to medical
now
to react to perch it's resetting systems
across sevastopol
lights transit maybe even communications
i think this is our big chance just go
now we might not have much time i'm
heading down to comms
okay all right then
so i need to get to transportation to be
able to go
where exactly let me save because i
haven't saved it in a while
oh that was a bit of a lot of hassle to
be able to do something that didn't
actually
work always good to know that my heart
efforts are appreciated around here and
everyone's going to have a happy fun
time hey
ho okay so get to the engineering
transit station
where am i going where am i going
there's a lot of choices here where am i
supposed to go
uh i i could do with some instruction
where am i going get to the uh go to the
san cristobal medical facility okay san
cristobal medical facility
is not here simon no medical ah
oh is it the one i don't know if that's
the one it doesn't tell me what's the
one
is that the one i don't know which one
you want me to go
lauren's assist expires on its avatation
i'm guessing
cymet tower engineering transit station
i don't know i don't know i'm guessing
this is what it is not much direction
going on here i could literally go
anywhere
oh no i know i couldn't because those
buttons aren't lit okay i was mistaken
because there was green lights by the
door i thought that i was supposed to do
that
so i got a little bit of free time while
i just chillax here and wait for the
aliens to rip out my face
oh my noisy ride has arrived oh could
you please squeal a little more before
you
park and open your doors for me that's
very good very good i'm out of
flamethrower fuel
okay there we go i was about to say any
minute now
i know i know simon simon summon
throwing the switch
i did something i didn't do it but i did
something and that's what's important
effort is half the battle
knowing is three quarters of the girth
four times seven is 39.
i'm not wrong
okay ambulance bay don't know where the
hell that is
bing bong find a short-range ambulance
so that's gonna help me get off this
damn station i need to go over
that way to be able to do this and we've
got hostels nearby so i know
for a fact that i am in trouble yay
also i wonder if it's optional that i
would be able to go back and do the ion
torch things to find whatever mysteries
may await them maybe there's an easter
egg in there i have no idea maybe
there's some secret to ripley's mother
going on there that i could find
although i feel like that would actually
be part of the actual story and not just
a sidequest easter egg that you could
find however
i would not put it past no actually i
would i wouldn't because this game is
very well designed and i actually am
liking it a lot not only am i liking it
a lot i liked it a lot so far and now
that the aliens are back
there's a real threat such that i might
be
killed oh
this is what required the ion torch yes
yes okay good good good
i really do feel like we might be
getting close to the end of the game
here i don't know if it's gonna be in
this episode or the next
but goddamn we are getting to some kind
of finality here because we're gonna get
off this damn
station and away from these damn dirty
aliens
taking over this damn [ __ ]
so where am i going now are there gonna
be aliens
waiting for me somewhere is this gonna
be a hostile takeover of
aliens i'm in trouble right now
things are gonna go horribly horribly
wrong for me aren't they wait i should
probably check my map a lot oh god damn
it i'm going the wrong way
again because i don't know what i'm
doing with my life
i just need to make it to default
because i'm so inclined to make my
brains like ooh explore the environment
and then it's like
no you have a job to do go do the job
first and then explore the environments
like
no but i wanna please no
whoa everything is on fire oh
this
so i haven't eaten all day i'm just
trying to cram down food because i fly
out tomorrow
i'm trying to get as many uh many videos
out as i can okay i came through that
door
that's when i blew everything up this is
where i first crawled through and i
encountered the alien menace
i was just trying to kill me dead i i
had a theory
that there wasn't just one alien did i
mention that in a previous video there
wasn't just one alien it was multiple
aliens
they just all happened to look the same
and they were all trying to kill us dead
and they were each out going out some
were eating people
some were maiming people but others
were taking them back to be harvested in
new aliens and there's a queen around
here somewhere
there is a queen i know that and i'm
going to face the queen someday soon
we may have thrown one out of the
airlock and that may in fact have killed
it
but there's more there's so much more
i wonder what one of these bolt guns
would do the daily
why why are you still here
how about stop shaking the goddamn place
you're dead please tell me that did not
summon
okay it didn't okay so which way do i
need to go i need to go through probably
it wants me to go through here so that i
can get there
i'm gonna do that
well i don't seem to see an alien around
here might be able to actually walk
because i would assume that me shooting
the freaking bolt gun would have
summoned a certain
somebody because items back in it does
someone magically replaced all the
things that i searched with items
oh so you were the first you were the
first i never connected the dots before
but you were the first
it's a terminal i never read oh we're
back
oh we're gonna do it this time no
alien's gonna get in my way now
it's gonna be so awesome i would have
known this i didn't read this all the
way through did i
i didn't did i turner we've had
something go down here in san cristobal
tape off the scene and make sure it's
not touched until garcia comes in with
forensics
keep this quiet for now i want total
silence
last thing this station needs is a panic
and one other thing
if i find out who leaked this to ransom
i'll make them eat their [ __ ] badge
he turned up quoted seeks and privileges
and had a ringside seat for the whole
goddamn mess
this is a serious incident i don't need
ransom making it more complicated
thanks weights you're a real pal i'm
glad that you're here
and that you're here to help everybody
isn't powerful enough
um probably not marlo seems like a bit
of a douche and i don't want to mess
with him at
all i want to go my own way i want to
learn my own things
and also i don't want to be eaten by an
alien can i have all those things
no okay so what am i supposed to do
find a level three upgrade for the
access tuner am i supposed to do it here
does there just happen to be a level
three upgrade right around oh
there is what do you know
good for me it was right here the whole
time exactly where i needed it at least
i don't have to go looping back and
forth trying to activate and react to
birds and gonna do
nothing i might be a little bitter about
that but that's okay i just wanted to
kill some aliens and it didn't work
i thought they oh good we've got even
more codes now
goody goody gumdrops also what letters
are those
are those alien language is that
prometheus language
oh i'm right here what about you
ricardo no regano
am i getting out of here oh my god i'm
getting out
i didn't expect it to end like this am i
getting out oh this can't be the end
i know it's not
oh
space space
oh there we go space
that is a big thing
space you mean the exit i could if i had
to find a way to hack through
that door in the beginning of the game i
would have been able to just hop on one
of those things
and get out of here also what about the
torrens
wait am i am i on the ship now
hello can you hear me
where am i now also why am i now
where am i where the hell am i
some doesn't seem right here the anissa
dora seems like it might have a bit of
an alien problem huh
that'll be good oh this is
just delightful so
uh yeah something horrible
that was intended to look like aliens
wasn't it
you designed that game developers you
made that
intentionally to look like an alien
didn't you you sons of [ __ ]
you're trying to spook me there's far
too much spoop around here the levels of
spoof are excessively high
i don't know much careful something's
gonna jump out of me
they're trying to spook me
yeah is that the sound of wind rustling
through here
barely been scraping a living the past
couple of years and the anissa door is
starting to look like the wrecks we
salvage
can't say the crew's been faring any
better
then we found that flight recorder it
belongs
extrapolate the path of the flight
recorder to try to find the wreck of the
nostromo
we got lucky found a distress signal and
now we're following it
this is it i can feel it in my bones
i always said he'd do right by me
i'm sure he did was that the lady that
had her chest bursted
marlow haste says he's just picked up
some kind of signal i've got lewis
trying to decode it now
could be from the nostromo want to come
up and see for yourself
technicians record report marlo i just
had to do some much-needed work on the
sublight engines the old girl was
complaining so loudly i'm surprised
something didn't fall off during last
jump
everything's holding together now but
she'll need a full overhaul
soon and not just for the core systems
we keep pushing her like this and we're
gonna end up being the only salvage crew
hitchhiking through deep space
it's gonna be an expensive job so let's
hope you're right about that beacon
it could be our last chance for a decent
paycheck anyway i had to reset the door
code afterwards the new one is 4-5-1-0
remember that everybody four five one
zero okay
we're outside sevastopol milo and foster
woke up first
she looked terrible meeks and me are
about to take a shuttle to the station
oh well this has got to break quality
procedures right
it's my little [ __ ] she's milo's wife
and things got heated
and meek's got a bloody nose so i don't
know
maybe the doctors will give her the all
clear and things can get to normal
but if they sniff it out when we get on
board i don't want any part of it
milo doesn't pay nearly enough for that
kind of noise yeah
screw marlow he's just a selfish prick
who's
my wife probably was the one that
entered chesapeake yeah
so why am i doing this what happened to
them what
is going on there's gonna be an alien on
this
i know there is you can't fool me i know
how this works
all these things are just falling apart
on the anissa dora
everything is just a pile of dookie well
those look fancy don't they
okay am i doing the right thing yeah
bring the inning store systems back
online
so i'm doing that right now let me
reload my flamethrower with what little
flamethrower fuel i got
so then hopefully if there is an alien i
might be able to distract it long enough
to
prolong my death for a few more seconds
before it murtalizes me
oh that is penile like okay here we go
oh damn it
i got it second time's a term sorry
everybody i'm a little tagged
okay then it's a weird internal
combustion engine of sorts
i'll just be on my way in case you're
basic power here back online doors
should be open
hopefully some light still no sign of
marla
okay ricardo probably didn't get that
because he's still on the ship
marlow where are you marlo
marlow he saved me a job
i only needed it offline temporarily i
had some things to fix
okay that sounded ominous and scary
marlow
come out come out wherever you are so
marble's way over there
marbabalo maybe you want to join my crew
taylor taylor marlow what are you
do come doing me quickly i got something
for you
what do you mean everyone on your crew
is pretty much
dead you're like the only one left
everyone else is just
why why even bother
uh whatever man you know what just i'll
play your game
you rogue and then you let taylor go
because i like taylor
i didn't think that taylor was double
crossing me and then we all have a happy
fun time and never talk about this again
okay
okay no all right i'll have to kill you
you don't have any androids do you whoa
whoa
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
i you piece of [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] i was not ready
god damn it [ __ ] off
piece of [ __ ] cock-ass piece of poopy
cock-ass piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
god i'll be back everybody hang on
okay we're back and i'm feeling much
more cheerful about life and everything
in general so we need to find
marlow but first we need to traverse the
darkness
and go through a place where there might
be an alien facehugger maybe you want to
join my crew
no
taylor marlow what are you
find me doing i got something for you
are you trying to
uh take these aliens and sell them on
the black market for a huge
profit because that seems like what
you're trying to do
and something tells me that that's a bad
idea
also how did you get that on here
whatever it was attached
itself to foster is dead i found it on
the floor by her bed i'll curl up like a
spider
foster said she felt fine by insisted on
putting her in this hypersleep
that thing must have done something to
her but maybe i can slow the process
sevastopol is the nearest station so i'm
going to get her checked out quarantine
will be no problem but i figure the
nostromo flight recorder
maybe the ticket in whatever we have to
do okay
wait oh denise this is marshall weights
of sevastopol
officially i should deny your request to
doc
sebastopol is currently being
decommissioned and i can't compromise
security for unscheduled vessels
however in the light of the property you
found
i will allow a small number of your crew
to dock
via a short range shuttle i must remind
you that sebastopol is entitled to a cut
of any reward
for return of said property once it's on
station
let me know your decision great job huh
so wage was trying to cut a profit and
then let the aliens on the ship
by trying to care for the fellow flight
mates
of this marlow character
well that looks ominous and dark why are
spaceships
make sure there's no chance of the human
race ever making contact with it again
because the moment it makes contact it's
one the company's never gonna know what
happened here
nobody is i won't allow it
okay so you're not trying to do it for
profit you're just in a bit of grief
because you lost your wife and you're
trying to take us all out with
it i'm assuming you're trying to blow up
the station
that seems like what you're trying to do
here uh you've got that kind of attitude
about you that screams
i'm going to take everyone down with me
which is not okay not okay
and again why was there a facehugger in
the other room so if you're not trying
to make it all for profit why was it
there
why was it there you want to riddle me
that question
bucko you want to answer me that one
friend sure do have oh these are the
hypersleep pods
for when they're doing uh really
long-term travel so that they can not
die
ding-dong okay what have you got here
hypersleep is one of those other
interesting science fiction things that
i wonder if we're ever going to get
because obviously even if we went to say
alpha centauri it'd take
hundreds of years we'd have to actually
have a ship that was going to
go generations just breeding
so that they would have people that
would be there when they arrive
it's interesting to say like that
probably a little crude but it's true
it's gotta be ooh flight recorder data
play recorded
added report personal message
this is for my daughter
hi amanda i'm recording this for you
my sweetheart and i hope you get to hear
it one day
you see i um i got into trouble
um my ship there was an accident
sweetheart and um we found
an alien creature it was very dangerous
and the only way we could stop it was to
destroy the ship
uh i'm okay i'm stuck on this lifeboat
long way out but we had to destroy
the ship we had to destroy the nostromo
we just couldn't risk bringing that
thing home with us
i needed to protect you
don't worry don't worry about me
i'm sure i'll see you very soon i love
you sweetheart
oh my god
finally got to hear the message i guess
that's good
oh hi hey taylor no
now you understand maybe
okay so what am i going to do about you
yeah i understand the reactor he'll turn
the reactor into a goddamn noob
you'll destroy the ship and the station
it will annihilate every trace of that
creature
ripley it's the only way i can't let it
live
and i'm not letting the company have it
or they'll just start the whole thing
over again
well he's got a point but it's not a
very good point i mean i agree
you should probably should just blow it
all up that was my we don't have to
you think she would want company suits
knowing the zip code of that creature
no one must know
yeah there you go good job taylor hit
him again hit him one more time
i think that was too late he set it
going
taylor i'll stop the overload you have
to help me go to that console
that all seems very bad
i need power sent to the auxiliary
generator look for the letters
a-u-x
yay okay what do i do i don't know what
i'm doing how'd i know
oh oh the fastest i've ever eat i mean
as hard as i can
no nukes please even though that'd be
actually fantastic to see
i always wanted to see a nuclear thing
maintenance terminal from auto to manual
do you see it
how much radiation is she getting ready
there taylor trust me
here we go here we go here we go thought
let's not mess this one up this is
for all the money oh so
quick i did it i'm good i'm good thank
you
now
good thing the fusion relay looks like
every single other relay i've ever seen
hit him again
hit him again really incentivizing you
to hit him against
tear itself apart
oh god taylor
jeez oh this game wait a minute
you just made me sit there and watch
watch her die
that's horrible oh god please yes thank
you why did that close right in front of
me
this is bad this is all kinds of bad
where am i going where am i going what
am i doing what am i doing i want to do
this wrong i'm not checking my map no no
not gonna check my map because i know
what i'm doing it's guiding me
okay come on get up get up ripley you're
a badass you can handle this
whoa okay that maybe you can't handle
not having gravity
whoa okay then
that's bad okay uh i have a flame
thrower is there any way i can turn it
to suck mode
if i had a moment to stop and appreciate
all this it'd be very cool by the way
so once again we went through all that
just haven't done nothing
great
little little speedier little little
speedier okay there we go
yay ooh so many emotions i have right
now
happy sad i got out but not only is
taylor dead but also
you know she heard the mother message
ricardo ricardo
took out the orbital stabilizers we're
back to fall from the sky
i'm trying to contact the torrents that
the cons are still locked the ambulance
you just dropped is screwed
the tomatoes are only way off this
okay so i gotta contact the torch why do
i have to do everything around here
okay whatever i'm i'm ripley i'm the
badass
we can take survivors i'll leave this
channel open
turns out so we can hear that but we
can't respond to that
why also why is the torrent just been
sitting there with no update and be like
i wonder if everything's okay on that
ship over there oh it does seem like
they're in a bit of a ball there
was that an alien i saw floating into
space no
no no no oh i'm back here
there's all of those doors oh this is
where all the ion torch things were oh
you're dead
what do they want to contact
so okay isn't ricardo part of siegel's
security
are these the survivors that have been
holding out trying to survive
okay so i found this now that i actually
have an ion torch and i can cut through
a giant steel door
i wonder what goodies are waiting to
hear oh seeking security's on this level
oh
well then i'm gonna be a survivor and
i'm gonna do just fine
also i need to save real bad because i
have not saved in a while
i would hate to have me die for some
stupid reason
like a little itty-bitty alien trying to
jump on my face
all stupidly did i mention it was stupid
if
that happens i would hate to have that
happen to anyone
okay good job well done ripley
okay where am i where the hell am i
what was that what was that you can't
just put in weird random ass
noises around here okay who's that who's
over there
who is there
what do i do about this
okay i'm okay i'm okay he's not an alien
so he's almost easy to sneak by whereas
these guys
i mean the aliens oh hi you're easy to
sneak by
apparently it really is easy
yeah you worry about that i'll worry
about how you're idiots
okay where am i going where am i going
okay so i need to go all the way around
to get to the relay facility i
can take this as a separate route to go
back around the other way i need to find
a save station though
god there isn't one anywhere they really
don't want me to be able to continue my
progress do they
they're just a big bunch of dookies
there shouldn't be one down here i don't
think anyone's down here
ah that die okay
doing good so far
hello so am i able to take these guys
out with one blow to the back of the
head because that would be very much
useful
remember when i used to have a lot of
trouble sneaking by these guys oh
those were the days i didn't know what
they was doing
i didn't know how to play the game i
didn't know anything about anything
okay hi
don't mind me you didn't see nothing did
you someone will send help soon
uh no then why would you start murdering
everybody
no you didn't see anything
oh how about we do this then
you want to play at this game come on
come on
i'll make it through this i promise
something's here i can hear it oh can
you now you should check that out then
oh it must be a very serious noise
no golly why don't you just stare at it
for like 10 hours
oh i just oh oh oh oh
oh okay um um um um um
here we go again here we go here we go
here we go again
ain't that weird huh yeah so weird
that might have actually done more bad
than good i don't even know if this
guy's gonna go for it nope he's not
okay our only chance is to smack him in
the back of the head
or apparently he's gonna go in that room
and i don't need to worry about him whoa
whoa what the hell
what the hell whoa whoa whoa hey whoa
geez ease it up with that shotgun there
you big bully what the hell he just
sprinted at me for no goddamn reason
okay who did that does anyone want to
fess up to crimes is it time to light on
i'm ripley jr
oh good stay point just exactly what i
need with no hostels nearby apparently
remember they just fire first i'm just
an innocent ripley lady
okay so either way i'm all out of time
for this one i have a feeling that the
next episode might be the last episode
of this series which would be pretty
cool but at the same time
man it'd be bittersweet because i've had
a really great time playing
with it anyway either way thank you all
so much for watching click the end of
days for more videos that i've done
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
oh my god no way
i'm sorry kid i'm sorry kid
coming to get you basically the entire
game is
based on this style and the world
and that's really interesting when you
start to think about how this world
actually is